is getting set for his final preseason
game uh of august this is gonna be
sunday night on nbc by the way al and
chris and the nbc gang getting ready for
their uh opening night which will be
between the buccaneers and the cowboys
but the browns and the falcons will be
on nbc the final game of the pre-season
period uh this sunday night before in
advance of the season opener of the
falcons at home against the philadelphia
eagles in week one he's arthur smith the
hc of the atl how are you arthur
great let's how you doing i'm doing fine
uh have you had a sit down chat ever
with al michaels before could this be
your first
arthur's no i've talked to him um all
right it's probably two years ago in the
preseason they were out of practice when
i was in tennessee okay
because i just wanted to hit on
something so i caught the end of that
yes sir were you trying to push
matt with natural light is that what it
was no uh coach uh i i was trying to
help him you know is his nickname okay
no i'm gonna he brought it up
rich this is my talk i understand the
head coach
coach
uh i i realized that his nickname was
maddie ice and it's been that way for a
very long time and i think personally
he's outgrown that that that sounds like
a nickname from high school college and
anything like that i think that he
deserves a nickname that is more
appropriate with his resume
and stature and i try to re-nickname him
the natural
[Laughter]
i thought he was he was working for like
a natural light no sponsorship you know
you got that travis matthew one so i
figured the same demographic yeah
interestingly interesting so
yeah
so so what what would you say uh as an
evaluator is he uh a top-flight
evaluator uh
what do you think of that nickname
change if i had to maybe put it in your
arsenal and tell matt that you think he
should do it what do you think
i think you should run with it i think i
think there's a lot of endorsement
opportunities okay
okay i think it's a good idea i really
do okay very good just if if you want at
all at any point today go to him and say
i spoke to rich i think you should go
with the natural and just and and just
see how that flies and i think that
would be wonderful for me i don't know
about you or for matt but uh that would
be great if you wouldn't mind i'll see
if i can just make it stick around here
so i'll try to help you out very good i
would see i go straight to the top of
the atlanta flow chart um how are you
going to approach preseason game number
three now that this is the last one of
these as opposed to previous seasons
when you'd have a fourth how was your
approach to this no it's been
interesting i think the preseason has
definitely been evolving probably the
last five or six years around the league
and it's
you know
people taking a lot of different
approaches in the past i think it was
pretty standard and the third one was
kind of the people just called the dress
rehearsal
um
but now with the the added game we've
got two weeks
it'll be interesting around league to
see how much people play you know the
guys they know are going to be on the
roster so
with us you know you know anticipation
we'll probably play everybody we'll make
the determination in the week but as a
staff like we're not going into some
heavy game plan but we need to get in
the rhythm of what our end season
schedule because we're year one so
it'll be kind of a hybrid we're not
going to go crazy
uh the game plan but
more likely we'll probably play just
about everybody so matt ryan the natural
uh
he he will get uh a snap or two on
sunday night we'll make that
determination by the end of the week
okay um but you know we're gonna get all
these guys ready to go and we'll see if
we put the natural in there thank you
sir for using that in a sentence that
means a lot to me you have no idea what
that means
thank you try to help you out thank you
the rest of the crew is uh is uh
lamenting because
yes
all of that yes you gotta move on
i love you but you gotta move on thank
you very much um so uh we could not help
but notice you're you're picking up of
josh rosen now not many times will i
talk uh to a head coach about a
quarterback that's acquired so late in
the preseason certainly when his
quarterback is knock on with healthy so
what what do you see in josh rosen what
do you what do you think of him and
expect
well you know just gotten to know him
obviously a pretty short time here so we
it was unfortunate what happened to aj
um and we have a roster spot and we
we worked a couple guys out and we
signed josh and uh we'll give an
opportunity to play sunday night at some
point so it's kind of you know you get a
week here to to really evaluate he
understands that and give him a chance
uh the good news is justin the camp he's
obviously got some armed talent and he's
got an interesting story so
like all these guys were given a fair
shot and
we'll get him ready to play and
how long do we decide but he will play
at some points on the night did you
evaluate were you was he on your radar
screen the year that he was drafted when
you were with tennessee did you guys i
watched him i mean it wasn't uh we knew
that year i mean for sure we weren't
gonna take a quarterback right um
early but uh you know i watched him and
for workout i mean that he's got
obviously arm talent and so you know i
don't
obviously women in the other buildings
he's been in but he'll get a fair shot
here
arthur smith here on the rich eisen show
and if i am not mistaken we have yet to
see kyle pitts on a pre-season football
field uh in a game and um
is your plan to put him out there
on sunday night right now uh we're
pretty sure we'll play but almost
play just about everybody um like i said
we we have we're going through the week
um
he said not no we're not necessarily
going through some elaborate game plan
but we just want to get in the routine
as a you know year one with the staff
and the players here what our routine is
and the plan is that we
anticipating playing most these guys
we'll make that final call on saturday
what have you seen out of him so far
that we don't see because we're not uh
we're not privy to it what have you seen
about kyle pitts
well i mean he's
from a character standpoint he's exactly
who we thought when we trapped him like
i said it's uh
it's unique he's not even 21 yet and you
know he's picked at that high there's a
lot of expectations thrown at you and
he's a very mature guy so he's handled
it um
he's coming right along as we expected
and we've got to put everything in
perspective but we think he should have
an impact um
this season i'm going to give the
prediction but we're we're very pleased
with how kyle's come off well and then
obviously you know uh you got two pretty
darn good tight ends right there and you
now have as we all know a julio jones
list receiving core but you got ridley
you got gage you got a whole bunch of
other kids
what is your offense going to look like
with uh
with with the natural at the helm
coach we feel like we've got a lot of
personal pieces um
and
with a lot of different ways that we can
effectively move the ball down the field
where it's like i said it
it helps when you do have flexibility at
a lot of spots so
uh you didn't mention lee smith as one
of our uh receiving weapons okay kind of
offensive but i i don't mean to look i i
you know i only have a certain amount of
time you know what i mean i know your
time is limited as well but uh i don't
mean to offend
yeah no we're excited so
i said we got a lot of guys that we feel
can can contribute to help move the
football right so
without giving away any uh
state secrets here yes uh
we'll be pretty excited going into week
one and you're not gonna see us can we
we gotta evaluate the way we vote for
this preseason we're trying to develop
guys
and we're trying to give them the same
comparison you know same type of plays
as we're going into there uh so we can
with the guys that are doing the first
half we're doing the second half so we
can make the best decisions
uh by tuesday on the roster so
that's kind of been our approach to
preseason and then obviously we'll see
what where it goes from week one arthur
smith atlanta falcons head coach first
year as that uh hc in the atl
prior to his final preseason game and
first regular season game right here on
the rich eisen show look i i know
talking about accomplishments in a
preseason is uh usually nothing because
you haven't done anything you haven't
accomplished anything but this
does deserve a kudo and congratulations
certainly from me i got coveted despite
being fully vaccinated over the summer
and um i know what it means to be
vaccinated how important it is to be
vaccinated your team reportedly one of
the first 100
vaccinated teams
in the nfl what did you tell your
players how did you approach this
situation
that led to such a remarkable number
that i congratulate you on coach
well
look it's you know it's a
i don't think it's a complicated issue
but the best way to put it i didn't
didn't pander all we ever tried to do
was inform our guys tell them to educate
themselves go talk to the medical
professionals and and to make the best
decision for you so we didn't try to sit
there and push anybody we didn't try to
guilt-trip anybody and you know a lot of
these things combination of certain guys
got it earlier than others which
probably helps um but everybody's got to
make their own choices and that's what
we push on here make your own choice
think for yourself and
and you know those guys all made the
decision to get it but i didn't think
there was anything we did special or
better than the other team
did you bring anybody in specifically to
address this issue to the team as a team
meeting have a doctor an epidemiologist
and you didn't do that no we we told
them that all those resources were
available through our
medical professionals and the ones
outside is to go educate yourself
um
you know it's
we're fortunate you know we look around
the country we're fortunate that there
is a vaccine available you know so i
again i don't get into political and
religious discussions but
uh the numbers are what they are and
i think we're pretty we're in pretty
good shape in this country the fact that
it is available
and you know
the modern technology came through so
um
like as you can see right now as it was
ripping through the country and you're
you were obviously one of them had the
breakthrough but it you know hopefully
it saved you from anything more dire so
of course and look you know i don't mean
to turn you as a head coach into an
epidemiologist nor do i want to be one
as a as a host of a show like this one
right and and you know and i know you
just mentioned the word politics but
when i got it uh last i i at no point
did the virus check my voter
registration card before
you know like that that that never
happened
so
again i'm just as a coach did you
did you uh
find out who had actually reached out to
your medical staff i'm i i i'm just
fascinated by this subject
i mean you're dealing with going in and
then you know to the point where you
just encourage guys to educate
themselves here here are what the facts
are
the facts
here's what's what their what the
expectations are
you know the protocols are going to be
and but you guys need to educate
yourself and i'm not going to sit here
and pander politically or religiously
because you've got to make a personal
choice right
and because i made mine doesn't make me
any better or think that i'm smarter i
did it because what i believed in and
you know so
um where common sense is you know lost
in this country uh you know there's
multiple reasons why is it that some
people can think you know that you and i
are idiots for going to get it but we
those are choices you and i made so
i'm happy with my decision all right and
then the last one for you on this
subject as a head coach uh are are you
relieved that you don't even have to
think about the subject of vaccination
that you know your team's got it and
that you now could just focus on another
task at hand
arthur smith well there's certain
release but um
you know it's
where you get those and the protocols
when you travel
uh you know you hope to you know that
was the one thing that uh
we they never done a good job in the
teams and we got every game played
uh but those a lot of the stress you
know every day when you woke up
and you had to be prepared like you know
on a game day uh players and coaches
where you you know you may test positive
and you try to do and there's a lot of
extra strength there's stress enough on
the games right and nobody's a victim
here you know we know what to sign up
for but
it is nice to
potentially not have her have to deal
with that on a sunday morning
i mean there's a case of exceptions
right if somebody were to get sick but
you don't anticipate waking up sunday
morning having that or some saturday's
test and
worrying about a guy being up or down
a couple hours before kickoff
few more minutes left with arthur smith
atlanta falcons head coach here on the
rich eisen show what is it gonna i again
i i i know you've got uh x's and o's to
deal with and you've got rosters and
you've got you know uh a lot going on on
your plate but you know what's it gonna
go through your your head when you're
getting ready to be the hc of the atl
against the philadelphia eagles week one
you're gonna maybe take a moment split
second that this is uh something you've
been working so hard towards for your
entire
career
coach yeah i mean it probably hit me at
different points um
it means obviously it's uh it's a hell
of an opportunity i feel fortunate to
get this opportunity and so
make sure to do the best yeah take
advantage of it and it is cool i mean
you take a step back but
you know your mind is so busy there's so
much going on
uh leading up to that game and you know
it's going to be a
hell of a hopefully held atmosphere in
atlanta that day
and the eagles are they're going to be a
heck of a challenge and they get
arguably you know
some of the best experienced lineman on
both sides of the ball
good skill position players good coaches
so it's it's exciting the opening day is
fun in the nfl because we're looking
forward to it i'm looking forward to it
for you okay coach so um just uh once
again um you know when you speak to al
if you want to have fun with him if you
just if you're if you're in the mood
i don't know when you're going to meet
with him but when you meet with him
um just casually in the middle of a
sentence mention that you've never eaten
a green vegetable in your entire life
and see his reaction because
he's never done that in his entire life
and you know he will jump out of his
seat he will not he'll be like what so
if you want to have some fun you could
say that or talk steak with him but i'm
that would be fun
and then outside of working in the
production there i think you would do
that if you just want to have you know
if you're just in the in a mood and you
want to just have a little bit of fun
with al just throw that out there and
just and then you know you could say
you're messing with them because who the
hell has never had a green vegetable in
their life um
it's al michaels and then the other one
is uh just casually work in the natural
too
yeah we'll try to get that going here
down here i'll use that in the team
meeting oh gosh
yes
created a monster coach
it's a natural light
sponsorship there you go you can work it
all together i like it making people
better that's all i try to do and i i
appreciate the time coach good luck uh
let's chat down the line you bet thank
you talk to you that's arthur smith the
head coach of the atlanta falcons hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here